so, Stream ist live, ups, geil, hab ich die erste Sekunde selbst geklippt, das ist natürlich
ja seine Folge, wer ist das?
ich muss mal den Chat pop-outen, auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, oder button dafür, ah, da, ist er nice, ultra nice, hyper nice
so, jetzt muss ich erstmal warten, bis Twitch das kapiert hat, kapiert hat, dass der Stream wirklich am Start ist, hat sich schon der erste drüber beschwert jetzt, dass ich die Streams nicht auf Twitter angekündigt hab, also, ach, das geht, aber gar nicht, du musst die Streams auf Twitter angekündigen
ja, ich weiß nicht, ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht so genau, man muss ja sagen, das betrifft nicht so viel, das interessiert wahrscheinlich nicht so viel
so, wir machen heute weiter, da wo wir gestern aufgehört haben, allerdings kann ich mir heute nicht die ganze Zeit wieder die Hardcore-Sampler-Geschichte geben, das ist zu viel
so, wir probieren heute mal aus, wie das mit Datenübertragung aussieht und basteln natürlich auch an der Stelle oben noch ein bisschen weiter
so, wer neu dabei ist, wer gestern nicht dabei war, vielleicht soll ich nochmal kurz erklären, was wir machen, oder waren gestern alle dabei, ich warte erstmal, bis der Stream richtig an ist, erstmal muss Kirby die Klappe halten, machen wir unsere Chillsong-Musik an
oh, wie Pepehands, nochmal erklären, weil ganz nice, und zwar, ähm, dann erzähl ich das jetzt schnell, mal Chrome aufmachen, ich hab mich gefragt, wie sprechen Japaner eigentlich Google Chrome aus
die hängen ja, die hängen an alles ja so komische Laute hinten dran, das ist dann wahrscheinlich krumme, oder irgendwie so, krumme, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie sprechen das, weiß das jemand
warum hab ich hier das ganze Zeug für ein Garten, 6 oder 12 paar Damen-Thermosorten, sehr interessant ja, jetzt kommts raus, exposed
gut, also, dann erklär ich das nochmal kurz, und zwar, ich hab hier so einen kleinen Controller, Mikro-Controller am Start, der ist nicht wirklich Mikro, das ist ein Development Board, also das da ist der eigentliche
nein, das ist noch nicht mal eine CPU, das ist so ein integriertes Ding halt, da ist alles möglich drin, Relan, Bluetooth, 3 CPU-Kerne, ein Low-Power-CPU-Kern und 2 240MHz-Kerne
und ich versuche eine Box zu bauen mit dem Controller drin, die die Bodenfeuchtigkeit misst und mir das ganze dann zurück überträgt nach Hause an meine Heimautomatisierung
der Knackpunkt an der ganzen Geschichte ist allerdings, und das ist wirklich ein großer Knackpunkt, so ungefähr, ich muss die Daten so ungefähr 1,5 Kilometer übertragen
und 1,5 Kilometer machst du nicht mit Bluetooth und machst du auch nicht mit W-Lan, machst du eigentlich außer mit Mobilfunk, sonst mit relativ wenig Sachen ja, und da haben wir gestern dran rumgebaut
und was wir gestern gemacht haben ist, wir haben es geschafft mit dem Low-Power-Prozessor, der auf dem ESP32-Controller drauf ist, regelmäßig den Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor abzufragen
Ja, Nicky, Richtfunk ist was, ich erzähle gleich, wie man das immer macht, ich meine, es steht auch im Titel drin, wie das Ganze funktioniert und wir haben es geschafft, den Low-Power-Prozessor abzufragen, während der Hauptcontroller schläft
und ihn dann aufzuwecken, wenn der was gemessen hat, über oder unter einem gewissen Wert, den wir, was wir haben wollen, dann weckt er die Haupt-CPU auf und die Haupt-CPU kann dann Sachen übertragen
und heute kümmern wir uns mal ein bisschen um das Übertragen, also sprich, wie kann ich denn Daten übertragen, so 1,5 Kilometer weit, so und ich habe im Chat schon gelesen, Satellitenschüssel, Richtfunk, naja, nicht so ganz, weil wir dürfen nicht vergessen
der Kram muss klein sein, also das muss in eine kleine Box passen, so, keine Ahnung, 20 mal 20 Zentimeter oder so, oder 15 mal 50 oder 8 mal 8 Zentimeter, kleine Box, so kleiner umso besser
und es darf nicht viel Strom verbrauchen, das kommt ja noch dazu, ich meine, wir hatten es gestern davon, was ist die logische Schlussfolgerung draus, wenn Sachen nicht viel Strom verbrauchen dürfen, es ist in der Regel saumäßig langsam
und das ist es, das ist es hier natürlich auch, ich habe was vergessen zu sagen, genau, lange Strecken übertragen mit möglichst wenig Strom, da ist die Schlussfolgerung eigentlich immer draus, die Datenübertragung ist ziemlich langsam
also da reden wir von ein paar Bits pro Sekunde, langsamer als Modem ist das ganze, deutlich langsamer als ein Modem, das ganze machen wir mit LoRa, LoRa ist eine Funktechnologie, die genau darauf ausgelegt ist, quasi mit relativ wenig Energie, also mit relativ wenig Stromverbrauch
also wir reden da so von, wenn es sendet, so 100, 150 milliampere, das ist nicht wirklich viel, milli wohlgemerkt und dementsprechend ist es halt langsam, aber ich meine für einen Sensor reicht es genug
wie heißen die Dinger, mit denen man ganz früh ins Internet ging, du meinst ein Akustikkoppler, sowas hier meinst du, sowas meinst du ne, Flow 96, ja das ist ja schon richtig antik
was brauchst du für einen Datendurchsatz, naja, sag mal mal so, ein Byte reicht, 8 Bit, 8 Bit vollkommen, und wohlgemerkt 8 Bit, nicht etwa jetzt pro Sekunde oder so
sag mal mal, sag mal mal 1, 2 Byte, alle 4 Stunden oder so, also ich brauch nicht viel, ich brauch wirklich nicht viel, ich mein der Sensor, man siehts ja hier irgendwo, hier hab ich ja den mal ausgegeben vom Sensor
der Sensor misst Werte von ungefähr, also wenn wir das mit dem Analog-Digital-Converter auslesen, den Sensor, dann misst der Sensor Werte von 1720 bis 3800
und die Werte müssen wir übertragen, ja, wobei da reicht ein Byte, doch, warte mal, ja es reicht nicht, aber 2 Byte reichen, weil 2 Byte sind 65000, irgendetwas
65000, 535, 36, ha, ja, ich kap die Ausrede, ich fang bei 0 an, dann sind es 65000, 535
einfach UKW-Sender, das geht nicht so gut durch Gebäude durch, wenn du da, also ich hab es ehrlich gesagt nicht ausprobiert, aber ich vermute mal, das wird nicht so gut
durch Gebäude, wobei, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt ist es vielleicht auch eine Sache, ich denke aber mal da wird es der Stromverbrauch und die Sichtlinie halt, also die vielen Gebäude auf dem Weg, wird es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen problematischer machen
Wie gesagt, wir machen das mit LoRa, das funktioniert auch, ich hab das schon ausprobiert, ich bin quasi mit einem Sender im Rucksack dorthin gelaufen und hatte den Empfänger hier bei mir im Arbeitszimmer auf dem Schrank liegen und es hat funktioniert
Man braucht keine Amateurfunklizenz, LoRa ist in Deutschland, also in Europa generell auf 433 Mhz oder auf 868 Mhz, in beiden, in beiden Frequenzen darf man eigentlich mehr oder weniger machen, was man will
Auf 868 Mhz muss man ein bisschen aufpassen, aber man darf glaube ich 30 Sekunden oder eine Minute irgendwie pro Stunde senden, was dicke ausreicht, so lange will ich das Ding ja auch gar nicht anlassen
So, machen wir weiter, wo fangen wir denn jetzt am besten an, mal kurz überlegen, ja achja, was mir gerade noch einfällt, bevor wir anfangen, kennt irgendjemand eine ordentliche Steckdosenleiste
Moment, da kommt noch was, nicht einfach eine ordentliche Steckdosenleiste, die man gescheit flashen kann und die man in Deutschland relativ zügig kaufen kann
Hat das übrigens schon mal jemand geguckt hier, die Serie, und wenn ja wie fandet ihr es, gibt es eigentlich irgendwie Steckdosen, gibt es noch eine Steckdosenleiste, die man das Motor flashen kann
Das da hier, das sieht da so aus, als kann man das flashen, Joywell, klingt schon mal übel, das ist noch China Hersteller, das Motor taugt nicht, sehr schön, ganz schön teuer
Reine 30 Euro, das ist eigentlich viel zu teuer, hast du Chernobyl geschaut, nein, bisschen teuer oder, mal kurz gucken hier drüben, bei Amazon, was ich da letztens für die Steckdosenleiste gekauft habe
Das war nur ein Bruchteil davon, ja, hier, 29 Euro und das waren 8 Stecker plus 4 USB, die ich mir letztens geholt habe, also null, sind die noch irgendwie ganz, sind die noch irgendwie bei 40 Euro, da kannst du die ganze Jahr selbst bauen
Ich mein okay, man kann sie flashen, allerdings kann man die meisten China Dinger flashen
Seit wann können Steckdosenleisten mehr als an und aus, das können Steckdosenleisten dann, wenn du da das Motor drauf flashen kannst, weiß nicht ob du das schon mal gesehen hast
Also sprich, alle, also die meisten China Dinger, die es so gibt, basieren eben auf diesem ESP866, das ist quasi so der kleine Puder von dem Controller, den wir gerade programmieren
Und fast alle China Sachen basieren eben auf diesem ESP866 Controller und das Motor ist super, hat auch richtig viele Sterne auf GitHub, ist ein super Custom Firmware für also ziemlich alle Geräte, die es gibt in dieser Richtung
Sieht ungefähr so aus, ja, genau ungefähr so sieht das aus, ja, so ungefähr sieht das dann auch aus, wenn man eine Steckdosenleiste damit flasht, man hat eine Webinterface, was man halt hier
Ich mein, wir sind ja im Jahr 2019, während auch Steckdosenleisten geflashed, selbstverständlich, dann hast du eine Webinterface, kannst da halt hier die einzelnen Sachen ein und ausschalten und die kommt halt ein bisschen drauf an, wie gut das Motor die jeweilige Steckdosenleiste unterstützt
Aber das Schöne ist, das Ganze kann natürlich sich ins WLAN hängen und kann einem an die Heimautomatisierung direkt quasi Status Sachen schicken, eventuell Stromverbrauch, wenn die Steckdosenleiste das auslesen kann
Oder halt noch viel besser, man kann von seiner Heimautomatisierung quasi jede einzelne Steckdose schalten bei so einer Steckdosenleiste, wobei die viel zu teuer ist hier, weiß gar nicht was da los ist
Es gibt schon seit Jahrzehnten quasi IP Steckdosenleisten fürs Rechenzentrum, ist im Prinzip auch sowas, allerdings viel, viel teurer, weil halt für Rechenzentrum Einsatz gedacht
Lieber ein Samsung Kühlschrank mit Reddit App, wie gesagt Leute, ich hab's ja, ich hab's schon vor Jahren im Video gesagt, das ist ein Trend, der wird nicht einfach so vorbeigehen und da müssen wir alle so ein bisschen drauf achten, dass wir es nicht zu sehr übertreiben
Also mit dieser ganzen IoT Geschichte, das war klar, dass das kommt und es war sowas von klar, dass die Hersteller versuchen wieder ihr eigenes Ding zu basteln, deswegen ist es besonders wichtig, dass man guckt, wenn man sich was kauft für Smart Home, Automatisierung
Dass man sich entweder was kauft, was von Haus aus offen ist oder was man flashen kann, ganze proprietäre Scheiße geht einem eher auf den Sack, als dass es hilft, zumal da bist du dann quasi wieder auf so Herstellerkladen angewiesen, was Updates angeht und sowas
Nicht übertreiben und er sagt, die Steckdosenleisten flashen, ich finde Steckdosenleisten flashen ist nicht übertrieben, lass mal überlegen, was wäre denn übertrieben, es ist ehrlich gesagt nicht viel, nicht viel übertrieben
Ja, Dings Alexa in der ganzen Wohnung verteilen finde ich übertrieben, ich weiß, dass viele sehen das genau umgedreht, die verteilen sich Alexa in der ganzen Wohnung und dass ich meine Steckdosenleiste flashe, finden sie bescheuert
Jetzt mal eine dumme Frage, wozu Steckdosenleiste flashen? Ja, dass ich die Steckdosenleiste remote schalten kann, weil wenn man jetzt mal das Ding nimmt, man davon abgesehen, dass das mal locker 15 Euro zu teuer ist
Und das flash ich, dann kann, also umgedreht von Haus aus, kannst du das halt nur mit der offiziellen China App machen, über die China Cloud die Steckdosenleiste schalten, wenn das flasht, kannst du lokal im Netzwerk die Steckdosen schalten
Ohne China Cloud, ohne China Firmware, die was weiß ich alles heim schickt, mir geht es viel eher darum, nicht, dass die China Software wirklich was heim schickt, weil dann könnte ich die immer noch im Netzwerk schicken, in ein eigenes Netz stecken, wo das nicht funktionieren würde
Sondern, dass ich die nicht ordentlich schalten kann, außer mit der offiziellen App
Und genau, so sieht halt das Webinterface davon aus, da gibt man dann seine hier Achmet, gibt man dann seinen WLAN ein und das kann man dann mit seiner Heimautomatisierungslösung verbinden, ist halt komplett offen
Äh, wer übrigens was sucht, der, also was man in die, ähm, in die, nicht die Steckdose, in den Lichtschalter, in die Schalter, unter den Putz in die Schalter einbauen kann, der sollte sich mal das da angucken, Shelly1
Die haben eine ziemlich blöde Domain, Shelly.cloud, die hauptsächliche, ähm, Seller ist, dass es ohne Cloud funktioniert, also das ist mal, das ist mal echt Next Level Big Brain, oder?
Man, man macht ein Produkt, dessen Hauptverkaufsargument ist, es benötigt keine Cloud, und was nimmt man als Adresse? Shelly.cloud
Was ist, das ist wirklich Massive, Massive Big Brain, äh, da gibt's nix
Ja, richtig Pfeifett
Choose my name sagt, ich finde die Talks von CCC zu IOT-Schwächen immer sehr lustig. Ja, ich auch, und die meisten Sachen, und die meisten Leute, die damit Probleme haben, sind eben gerade die, die irgendein vorkonfiguriertes Zeug von denen im Hersteller nehmen. Ich will nicht sagen, dass man sein eigenes Zeug nicht auferkacken kann, aber da ist man wenigstens selber dran schuld
Seehofer will er Zugriff auf Alexa, will er das echt? Ach
Er zählt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist
Ja, es gibt Apps für Steckdosenleisten
Ja, die kannst du, also das kommt ein bisschen, das kommt natürlich ein bisschen auf die, auf die Steckdosenleiste und die Software dafür an, aber wenn man die hier mit der offiziellen App einzeln schalten kann, also wie gesagt, die ist viel zu teuer, da will ich ne günstigere suchen, und man die flashen kann mit zum Beispiel das Motor, dann kannst du jede einzelne Steckdose kannst du, kannst du schalten, ja
Neko-chan sagte, ich würde mir niemals so einen Smart-TV ins Wohnzimmer stellen, ich hab einen, allerdings benutze ich die Smart-Funktion nicht
Ist auch schon irgendwie bescheuert, ich hab nen, nen, nen, Sony?
Ein Sony-Fernseher und der hat ja nen Android, also das Embedded Android-Dings, ne, ne, Android-TV drauf
Allerdings darf das Ding nicht ins Netzwerk und nicht ins WLAN
Darf nirgends wohin
Also nur nicht mal eingerichtet, es ist nicht so, dass es geplockt ist oder so, dass es nur nicht mal eingerichtet
Was darf, ist mein Nvidia-Shield, die dran hängt
Naja, okay, ähm, also, ich hab hier, ich hab hier, ich hab hier, ich hab hier, ich hab hier, ich hab hier, ich hab hier
Naja, okay, ähm, wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich?
Guck mal, die haben neue Sachen
Haben sie ein neues
Das Shelly-Energy-Meter, ach doch, das ist ganz interessant
Ach, ich hab euch ja noch gar nicht meine krasse Konstruktion im Keller gezeigt
Weiß gar nicht, ob ich euch das, ob ich da irgendwie Follows von hab
Ich hab im Keller zum Strom auslesen, hab ich was schönes gebastelt
Auch mit dem ESP866, und zwar, ähm, wir haben da noch so einen uralt Stromzähler
Sowas hier
Sowas, was man mal vor 5000 Jahren hatte
Kennt vielleicht noch der eine oder andere
Sowas haben wir, ups, sowas haben wir noch im Keller hängen
Das ist richtig MonkaS
Na gut, also, zumindest, das Ding hier vorne dreht sich halt, und dann läuft ab und zu so ein roter Strich vorbei
Und wenn ein roter Strich vorbei läuft, ist halt eine Einheit, äh, um
Und wie viel, was eine Einheit ist, steht hier quasi neben, irgendwo dann irgendwie auf dem Zähler drauf
So, und, ähm, man hat keine Chance hier irgendwie was digital abzugreifen
Weil, ich mein, ehrlich gesagt, sieht das Ding in irgendeiner Weise digital aus
Das sieht aus wie 1905
So, und da hab ich, ähm
Ja, das zählt als veraltet
Die sind aktuell, die sind aktuell ganz scharf drauf, den Leuten, ähm, neue Stromzähler zu verkaufen
Beziehungsweise zu installieren, wo sie sich nicht gegen wehren können
Ich hab schon gehört, dass angeblich manche Stadtwerke versuchen, quasi WLAN Zugang zu bekommen
Bei den Leuten, dass die ihre Stromzähler in die Datenheim schicken können
Also, wenn mich mal wirklich ernsthaft von den Stadtwerken jemand fragt, ob sie WLAN Zugang kriegen
Bei mir, dass sie ihre Stromsachen verschicken können, dann muss ich echt auslachen, äh
Bimpistisch, Alter, staubs geht los, äh
Sind die noch, sind die noch ganz, sind die noch irgendwie ganz, ganz bei Trost, oder was?
Ach ja, genau, ähm, das stimmt, der Flow 96, oder was hat der Flow 96 gesagt?
Ja, mit Plinken, genau, so einen haben wir nämlich auch
Also, es ist nämlich so, dass, also wir haben, der Hauptzähler, der eigentlich, der einzig offizielle Zähler, den wir haben, ist der
Im Keller, so, so ein uralt Ding
Und, ähm, ich hab für den ersten Stock hier, hab ich noch einen, noch einen extra Zähler
Der ist schon ein bisschen moderner, der hat so eine LED, die blinkt
So, und jetzt, jetzt pass mal auf, jetzt hab ich was richtig Nices gebaut
Und zwar, hier sieht man es ja, hier läuft dann ab und zu so ein Strich durch, ne, und der Strich ist dann durch
Genau, hier steht eine Kilowattstunde, ist also 600 mal der Strich
Das ist aber noch ganz alter, das sieht ja aus wie aus einem U-Boot, oder so
Naja, zumindest hab ich mir, hab ich mir was gebaut, wie man das auslesen kann
Und zwar, hab ich mir einen Linesensor gekauft
Wie ist das Ding? IR Linesensor, genau, den da
Also, sieht fast genauso aus, nicht ganz so
Sowas hab ich mir hier gekauft, der ist eigentlich dafür da
Pass mal auf, das ist, das ist absolut next level, äh, huge, huge brain, ähm, Bild
Ich zeig euch mal, wofür ein Linesensor überhaupt da ist
Was der, wofür, was für ein Linesensor, was der macht
Das ist auch ein Video von, wann ist das? 1970?
Ah, 2012
Ja, guck, also ein Linesensor macht sowas hier eigentlich
Das kann man, da kann man halt Linien verfolgen lassen zum Beispiel, wenn man Roboter baut oder sowas
So, und was ich jetzt gemacht hab, ich hab mir so ein Linesensor geholt
Hab mir mit dem 3D Drucker ein Gehäuse ausgedruckt
Und, ähm, hab den Linesensor mit nem ESP
Mit nem, kann ich mal zeigen welcher
So nem kleinen Ding hier, so nem kleinen Controller
Hab ich den Sensor auf den, auf den Zähler gepappt
Mit nem bisschen Klebeband
Und der hängt hier schräg drauf, der Linesensor
Also das Ding, genauso ungefähr in der Position, wie das jetzt ist
Ähm, ein Video über den 3D Drucker wäre was
Ja, muss ich mal gucken, also dies ist eigentlich relativ unspektakulär
Man lädt sich nen Sketch runter, nee nen Model runter, sliced das, lädt es hoch
Und guckt dem Ding dann 5 Stunden beim Drucken zu
So, und
Der sitzt dann quasi mit den LEDs da drauf
So hier schräg, so, hier so ungefähr in der Ecke sitzt der
Und wenn dann diese, diese schwarze, dieser schwarze Strich vorbeikommt
Man muss den hier unten, äh, man muss den hier ein bisschen die Empfindlichkeit einstellen
Und wenn dann der schwarze Strich vorbeikommt
Dann registriert das dieser Linesensor, weil der halt denkt, oh die Line ist weg
Also das ist dann quasi inverted, muss man sich das denken
Das erkennt die ganze Zeit, ihr habt den Roboter gerade gesehen, der der Linie nachgefahren ist, ne
Der sieht die ganze Zeit, wir sind auf der Linie, wir sind auf der Linie, wir sind auf der Linie
So, und dann kommt der schwarze Strich und dann sagt der Sensor auf einmal, oh wir sind nicht mehr auf der Linie
Ja, und, und dann kriegst du nen Signal
So, und ich find das ist übelst, das ist übelst Next Level Shit, ja
Und so, so, so mess ich grad meinen Strom unten
Im Keller, ich lass den, ich lass den Sensor mitzählen
Ja, und ähm, dann hab ich noch für, für
Oben, also für den ersten Stock
Also jetzt, wo ich auch grad sitze im Endeffekt
Dort hab ich noch was anderes, ist auch, ist auch am, die ist auch am gleichen Controller dran
Das schöne an diesen, an diesen Dingern ist, erstens der ist mini, er ist klein
Und er hat, ähm, genug GPIOs für so alles was man braucht
Du hast irgendwie acht GPIOs, du hast nen analog-digital-Converter und seriell und, und gedönst
Also das ist, das ist wirklich ganz schön
Und das Schöne ist halt, das passt auch alles in den Schaltschrank unten rein, da hast du keine Kabel raushängen oder so
Ähm, und oben hab ich einen etwas neueren, für den ersten Stock haben wir hier einen etwas neueren Stromzähler
Nämlich so einen hier
Ja, der sieht ungefähr so aus wie der
Gucken, vielleicht gibt's da auch einen mit LED
Guck mal, hier siehst du auch die Leute, die die Dinger nachgebastelt haben
Die haben ja richtig Progress heute schon im Stream gemacht
Ja, ungefähr so, und der Stromzähler hat so eine LED an der Stelle
Und dort hab ich nen, sowas hier drauf gepappt
Also sprich, das ist ein Sensor, der erkennt Licht, je nachdem wie hell was ist
Und, ähm
Ja, so, so ungefähr sieht das Ding aus
Und den hab ich einfach über die LED gehängt
Und wenn die LED blinkt, dann krieg ich einfach nen Signal auf dem Sensor, weil das halt kurz licht
Und dann kann ich das zählen, so, und die Sachen stimmen ziemlich genau
Ich hab das jetzt nach ein paar, ich hab das jetzt schon ein paar Wochen laufen
Und, äh, hab mal nachgeschaut, also das kommt ziemlich gut hin, was die Dinger als Verbrauchmessung, was unten der Zähler zählt
Also ich find, das ist schon echt, das ist schon ein Übel, ne?
Tja, wo sind wir jetzt hier stehen geblieben?
Ganz, ganz viele Sampler gedürnt
Magst du in Fachinformatik, dann machst du aber viel Elektronik
Äh, ich mach im Prinzip das, was mich interessiert
Ist auch scheißegal, das ist übrigens ne Sache, ne?
Sollte eigentlich jeder machen
Scheiß drauf, über den Teller heranschauen schadet keinem
Und außerdem, umso mehr man weiß, umso besser
Zumal man Spaß macht, ne?
So, ähm, aber jetzt mal zurück
Zu programmieren
Ich würde sagen, wir machen mal kurz nen neuen
Wir machen mal
Ein neues Projekt auf
Weil ich will hier nicht so viel dran rumbasteln, weil das ist jetzt in einem Zustand, das funktioniert
Wir könnten übrigens das mal eine Runde Git committen, würd ich sagen
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt
Weil, wer weiß, was ich hier noch drinnen ändere, ich weiß, dass der
Äh, hallo, ich will diesen Ordner öffnen
Open in Explorer, so rum
Ich muss nämlich gucken, wo das Ganze liegt
Blablabla, Documents, Blablabla, Project, Streamtest, okay
Da, wie das, äh, das committen wir grad mal ne Runde
Ins Git
Oder, wie es die coolen Leute sagen, ins Shit
Ins Shit, sagen die coolen Leute, ja
Was übrigens komplett der Blödsinn ist
Aber es gibt auch Leute, die sagen Gyra oder Emerson oder so
Es gibt halt welche, die müssen das besonders geil aussprechen
Äh, vielleicht sollten wir noch ein paar Sachen mal
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal ein paar Sachen ins Git Ignore schreiben
Nämlich im Prinzip alles
Alles, was wir als Code ist, will ich nicht committen
Und alles, wo sind die Binaries drinne?
Wo sind die Binaries drinne?
Ja
Ah ne, committe da auch nicht, okay
Ah, dann ist es eigentlich in Ordnung
Okay, Git Init
Git Status
Ja, hält sich doch in Grenzen
Include, was ist denn in Include?
Nix, na gut, dann können wir committen
Ach ne, ist ja ein neues Repo
Einfach nur, falls sich jetzt irgendwas ändert, dass ich weiß, dass
Ich hab nen Zustand, nämlich weiß, dass es funktioniert
So, jetzt machen wir mal ein neues Projekt und jetzt probieren wir mal
Äh, was, äh, über Laura zu schicken
Ich mein, wir können jetzt keine 1,5 Kilometer
Im Stream hier übertragen
Ähm, sondern nur ungefähr, keine Ahnung
Von hier bis, bis in Hof
Aber wir wissen schon, ob es funktioniert, ja?
Und ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab die Entfernung schon ausprobiert
Ich weiß, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert, somit keine Ahnung
Ein paar Bit, ein paar Bit, äh, alle 5 Sekunden
Ich werde hier zwar davon gehadet, aber ich nutze SVN
Flow 96, ich bin in der Ansicht, das soll jeder verwenden, was er will
Und das, was am besten zu der jeweiligen Geschichte passt
Wenn, wenn du dich, wenn du mit SVN zufrieden bist, dann
Wozu, ja?
Wenn das funktioniert
So, äh, was mach ich denn hier?
Neues Projekt anlegen will ich
Neues Projekt, äh
Dora Tests
Die haben immer noch ein Node MCU
32 Board
Sack
Gut, was wir als erstes machen, oh scheiße, ich muss den Kram ja noch verkabeln
Oh, da hab ich jetzt Bock drauf
Also, das, das Verkabeln ist tatsächlich, also die, die Jumperkabel, die
Wie, wie, wie heißen die Dinger eigentlich?
Diese Dupontkabel, Dupontkabel
Wie spricht man das eigentlich richtig aus?
Dupont
Kabel
Dupor-Kabel
Wenn es Französisch ist, ist es bestimmt Dupor-Kabel oder so
Oder, oder wenn es Französisch ist, ist es Dupol oder so
Dupol-Kabel, ich kann
Ja, man kann ja einfach Jumperkabel sagen, das ist, äh, viel, viel einfacher
Ich würd sagen, es heißt Dupont
Ja, das Verkabeln wird noch ein bisschen eklig
Da muss ich mir nämlich mal, also Node MCU
Ein Bild suchen, wie die Pins hier belegt sind
Also, ich weiß, wo ich den ganzen Krempel anschließen muss
Und zwar, ich hab ja hier ein Modul
Ein Lora-Modul
Nicht, kein, kein fertiges Board, also ich hab wirklich das hier, ich hab das nackte Modul hier
Das sieht auch genau so aus, nur, dass ich ein RF
Ja, genau, genau das Modul hab ich hier, genau das
Und das ist, das ist nicht groß, ne, das ist, das sieht hier so groß aus, das ist, ähm
Kleiner als, bisschen, ja ungefähr wie mein Daumennagel, also es ist nicht groß
Dupont
Dupont könnte auch sein
Hehehehe, das ist eine sehr coole Aussprache von Jira
Jira
Ähm, genau, und ich hab jetzt
Hier überall
Seht's jetzt nicht, aber ich hab das Modul hier erlegen
Ich hab mir hier überall Pins dran gelötet
Man braucht nicht alles, man braucht nur
Mal gucken, ob wir hier eins mit Beschriftung finden, genau, hier findet man eins mit Beschriftung
Wir brauchen nur, ähm
Einen der Crown Pins anzulöten
Äh, hier fehlt was, oder?
Sagt man noch, fehlt, fehlt hier nicht irgendwie so? So die Hälfte irgendwie?
Oder ist es die super, super advancede, äh, China-Sparmaßnahme von Chips jetzt?
Dass die Löcher zum Löten keine Löcher mehr sind, sondern nur noch Halbkreise
Gut, wie dem auch sei, also meins hat, äh, komplette, komplette Anschlüsse
Ähm
Und wir brauchen von diesen Pins, brauchen wir nicht alles
Wir brauchen einen der Crown Anschlüsse
Hier ist die Antenne dran
Die Antenne ist bei mir gerade absolut advanced
Das ist ein, äh, ungefähr neun Zentimeter langes Kabel, was ich dran gelötet hab
Einfach stinknormales Kabel
Beste Antenne
Dann brauchen wir 3,3 Volt
Dann brauchen wir
Die, äh, Datenübertragungs Pins
Und das war's
Also insgesamt acht Anschlüsse oder so
So und ich muss den Mist jetzt, ich muss den Mist jetzt verkabeln hier nebenbei
Ähm
Also, Crown kommt
Oben
Rechts hin
Okay
Dann haben wir, äh,
Ich hasse so, gefuddelt, ja
Vor allem, wenn's mehr als drei, drei Kabel zu stecken sind, krieg ich schon immer Anfälle
Weil da musst du immer ganz genau gucken, dass du nicht aus Versehen Mist anschließt, weil das kann auch mal nach hinten losgehen
So, dann fangen wir jetzt an
Das ist übrigens das falsche Modul, was ich euch hier zeige
Von der Beschriftung her
Genau, die treffen's von der Beschriftung her eher
Ist egal, ich schließ den grade jetzt mal schnell an
Dann haben wir Mosi-Miso-Dings-Anschluss
MSS-Anschluss
Dann haben wir
Was ist das hier?
Reset
SCK
Reset machen wir an 25
Hallo
Umgefrickel, äh
Umgefrickel
E
Die Null, hier dran
Okay, so, schauen wir mal, ob ich den Kram jetzt richtig verkabelt hab
Über was für eine Schnittstelle kommuniziert das, um ehrlich zu sein, bin ich mir da nicht
Äh, ach doch, hier, äh, SPI
Hab grad den Anfang gelesen, hab gesagt, was soll das sein, SPI, ignorieren wir mal das V
Also ich hab's jetzt so angeschlossen
Äh, hier ist ein Kabel dran, da, da, da
Äh, da
25, äh, wo, wo ist denn 25
Da ist ein Kabel dran für Reset
Okay
Ähm, probieren wir das mal aus
Empfänger, wir müssen uns mal auf meinen Empfänger verbinden
Ja, Telnet, absolut Highend-Programme heute hier
Das ist mein
LoRa-Empfänger
Der empfängt halt gerade nichts
Der empfängt nichts
So, dann probieren wir das Ganze mal aus
Ja, Serious Max
Ich müsste eigentlich so viel Projekte hier noch fertig machen
Also wohl Stream, als auch hier bei mir daheim an sich
Das, das werd ich alles nie hinkriegen, ja
Da müsste ich mal ein halbes Jahr Urlaub nehmen
Mit dem, was du machst, kann ich nichts anfangen, finde ich Streams aber mega cool
Es ist, es ist cool, wenn dir das gefällt, obwohl du nichts damit anfangen kannst
Das ist nice, vielleicht lernst du ja noch etwas
Vielleicht interessiert es dich ja doch irgendwann
Oder interessiert dich jetzt schon und du sagst, vielleicht ist jetzt was dabei
So, okay, wir brauchen erstmal unsere LoRa-Library, die wir
Einbinden können
Libraries
LoRa
Install
Test
Oh
Include
Hallo
Ein bisschen Include
Ob ich jetzt im falschen Projekt installiert gerade
Oder ist das Ding einfach nur lahm
Okay, wir sollten nicht allzu viel auf Visual Studio geben
Weil es funktioniert
Ich mach das mal kurz zu und wieder auf, das spackt bestimmt
Irgendwie rum gerade
Ah, jetzt funktioniert
Okay
Was auch immer, ich glaube jetzt erkennt es alles oder
Ja, okay, warum weiß man nicht
Äh
Speed für unsere serielle Schnittstelle noch anpassen
So
Und jetzt mal kurz gucken ob
Prinzipiell das Ding lebt und was ausgibt
Weil es könnte ja auch sein
Weil es könnte ja auch sein, dass ich das so falsch
Verkabelt habe
Dass es jetzt kaputt ist oder so, weiß ja nie
Ich hätte mal eine Frage, für was ist CMD er gut
Ist das ein CMD Ersatz oder kann der mehr
Also ist ein CMD Ersatz der, wer hätte das gedacht tatsächlich mehr kann
Alter
Kann ich mal irgendwie richtig tippen jetzt
Okay, Test, Test, Test, Test funktioniert sehr schön
Allerdings
Microsoft hat jetzt eine neue Konsole habe ich gelesen
Oder sind dabei gerade eine neue Konsole
Neue Standardkonsole in Anwendung für Windows zu entwickeln
Habe ich letztens irgendwas gelesen
New Console for Windows, it's open source
Das müssen wir uns angucken
Habt ihr das schon mal aus
45K Sterne
Da sieht man mal
Dann sieht man mal was die Leute, wie scheiße CMD ist
Wenn Microsoft einfach nur
Ein neues Terminal Programm rausbringen muss
Und es bringt, gibt einfach mal 45.000 Sterne
No binaries yet, very early Alphas
Also sowas wie Pubke quasi, so wie Pubke seit 5 Jahren
Okay, es gibt es doch nicht zum Download
Also selbst kompilieren tue ich mir jetzt die neue Windows Konsole nicht
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt
Pubke ist eSports ready, ja das ist genauso eSports ready wie Overwatch
Wobei Pubke eSport ist ja noch, noch schlimmer
Ich hab mal in ein Turnier geguckt
Da hat Dings mitgespielt, Eska, den kennen vielleicht die eine oder andere noch von Overwatch
Und das war, ey Pubke eSport, das war das größte Campen überhaupt
Am Ende hat ein Team gewonnen, was die ganze Runde nichts gemacht hat
Einfach nur schön in der Grube gelegen
Und am Ende die letzten zwei verbliebenen gebashed
So, GG
Nice, easy clap
Kein Problem, also so war zumindest das erste
Und einzige Pubketurnier, oder Turniermatch was ich mir angeguckt hab
Okay, dann probieren wir jetzt mal ob das hier funktioniert
Ähm, nein das muss ich da drinnen lassen
Also wir versuchen jetzt mal was per Lora zu übertragen an meinen Empfänger
Der hier unten quasi vor der Tür steht
Also am Hauseingang steht ja
Wir sehen ja auch gleich schon wie gut die Empfangsstärke ist
Bei Overwatch eSport, ey ich hab mir jetzt immer noch komplett unverständlich
Warum 70.000 Leute Overwatch League gucken
Da sind wahrscheinlich mehr Leute als Overwatch im ranked online hat
Insgesamt
Im Monat
Also, Unic Players
Als Bots
Okay, ähm
So jetzt muss wir uns mal von der Library angucken
Ah da haben wir doch die Lora, das haben wir doch schon
Genau wie das funktioniert hat
Examples
Sender
Beginn, beginn, beginn, okay
Das ist jetzt relativ simpel, allerdings stimmt die Frequenz nicht
Wir brauchen, ähm, wir brauchen 800
886, äh ne 868 Mhz
868 brauchen wir
Failed, und dann machen wir keine Endlosschleife, das ist total beknackt
Sondern wir restarten nach einem Delay
Also eine Endlosschleife einbauen, ich weiß nicht, das machen ganz viele
In irgendwelchen Beispielprogrammen
Das hatte den Nachteil, du siehst in der Debug Ausgabe nichts und es passiert auch nichts
Obwohl das Ding in der Endlosschleife hängt
Was hältst du von WSL, Windows Subsystem für Linux, ich freu mich
Äh, ich weiß nicht was die Version 2 bringt, ich hoffe man kann dann auch ordentlich auf Datalsysteme und Sachen zugreifen
Weil du konntest ja beispielsweise keine, ich glaub Summer Mounts gingen nicht richtig
Ähm, ich persönlich bevorzuge eine Linux VM
Für das Zeug, aber
Für Sachen die man halt unbedingt unter Windows machen muss
Ist das schon eine ganz coole Geschichte
Es geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung
Also seit der neue Microsoft Chef am Start ist
Macht Microsoft eh viele sinnvolle Sachen
Ich mein, überlegt euch mal zu Zeiten von Stühle, Werf, Ballmer
Ähm
Hätte man das da jemals für möglich gehalten
Dass Microsoft der größte Open Source
Ähm
Lieferant ist das falsche Begriff für
Größte Open Source Contributor, wobei das ja quasi sowas wie ein Lieferant
Der, der sich am meisten an Open Source Projekten auf GitHub beteiligt
Und die größten Open Source Projekte auf GitHub hat
Hätte man das zu Ballmers Zeiten wirklich vermutet, das ich glaube nicht
So
Ok, wir müssen nochmal unsere Pins richtig verteilen
Pins, also
Das, das definen wir mal
Was wir für, was wir für Pins brauchen
Ähm, wir brauchen
Reset habe ich gesagt auf 25, ne
Wir haben IO
Auf 2
Wobei das auf 2 glaube ich ziemlich bescheuert
Ist, weil
Weil die LED die eingebaut ist schon auf 2 ist
Naja, mal schauen
So, ist auf 2
Ähm, dann habe ich noch
Ich glaube das wars
Die Default Settings müssten für den Rest eigentlich passen
So, was wir dann noch mal
Anlegen können ist ähm
Die Frequenz nehmen wir hier
Vielleicht wollen wir die ja mal später ändern
Dann brauchen wir noch die Bandbreite, da nehmen wir
Ähm
Bandbreite nehmen wir die hier
Und das
Spreading Factor nehmen wir mal 7
Ok
Version 2 von WSL soll
Echte VM sein, ok
Eine echte, eine echte Linux VM
Ja, aber da kann ich mir doch auch gleich für immer Workstation mit der Linux VM nehmen, oder?
Ich, äh, gut, ich meine die Vorteile von WSL
Mit der Windows Integration müssten ja schon da bleiben
Dafür wird Google immer unfreundlicher
Open Source gegenüber
Ja, Google, was mit Google los ist, verstehe ich eh nicht so genau
Also, naja, was heißt verstehen, ich kann es mir schon ganz gut
Schon ganz gut überlegen
Aber mir geht es auf den Sack
Vor allem, dass Google
An vielen Stellen immer mehr nervt
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Facebook
Facebook ist zwar nach wie vor so das größte
Social Network und sowas, was es gibt, aber ich kenne niemand
Und das habe ich schon 5000 mal im Stream gesagt, auch in Videos
Ich kenne niemand, der gerne Facebook verwendet
Das ist sogar so schlimm, dass
Jüngere Leute heutzutage sagen, Facebook ist
Quasi tote Plattform für sie
Was hat der, warum, was stört er sich am If
Achso, hier, er denkt
Das ist eine Quasi-Plattform
Schon geil, oder?
Und niemand benutzt
Gerne Facebook
So, und in diese Richtung habe ich das Gefühl, geht Google
Auch langsam, es gibt keine Alternative zu YouTube
Es gibt keine richtige Alternative zu Google Mail, es gibt keine richtige Alternative
Zur Google Suche, wobei das stimmt nicht so ganz
Ich verwende immer öfters in letzter Zeit
Google Go anstatt Google, aber im Prinzip
Von der Grundidee her
Es gibt da wenig Alternativen zu
Zu den großen Google Produkten und Google
Hat ja in letzter Zeit auch ein paar Sachen wieder gerissen
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch diese Nest-Thermostate
Was sagen
Die Dinger hier
Also ich habe keins, ich habe mich damals dagegen entschieden
Zu verwenden, nämlich, weil es von Google ist
Und mir von Anfang an klar war, sobald Google
Kein Bock mehr auf den Scheiß hat
Bist du weg vom Fenster
Und dreimal dürft ihr raten, Chat, was meint ihr
Was ist vor ungefähr zwei Monaten passiert
Mit Nest
Nest-Thermostaten
Ich war nicht weg vom Fenster, ich habe ja keins
Software-Support eingestellt, ja so ungefähr
Google hat gesagt, also man konnte diese Nest-Dinger
Über eine
Api, das war so eine Hybrid-Geschichte
Das lief zwar alles bei denen, allerdings
Konntest du es trotzdem in eigene Software und in eigene
Heimautomatik sehr gut einbinden, weil es eine
Weil es eine eigene Api hat zum ansprechen
Es war natürlich schon teilweise affig
Ich habe es gelesen, dass Leute gesagt haben
Mein Nest-Thermostat geht nicht, es ist minus 20 Grad draußen
Und meine Heizung heizt nicht
Weil mein Thermostat keine Verbindung zur Cloud hat
So und
Vor zwei Monaten hat Google gesagt
Fickt euch, wir stellen die Nest-Api ein
Und jetzt geht Nest nur noch über Google Assistant
Die Freude, die Freude bei den Leuten war natürlich
Wieder riesengroß
Jetzt haben sich im Prinzip alle darüber aufgeregt, dass sie damals Nest gekauft haben
Und ich habe mir
Damals schon gedacht, den Scheiß holst du dir nicht
Bei mir läuft das anders
Ich habe einen Raspberry Pi Zero
Mit, also unten an meiner
Heizung, da kann ich auslesen und theoretisch auch
Einfach drüber schalten
Den Betriebsmodus und sowas
Und ich habe an manchen Heizungen, wo es drauf ankommt
Den C-Wave-Thermostat direkt am Heizkörper dran
Anstatt zu einem Drehding
Ich habe damals schon so genau die Daseinsberechtigung
Von Nest-Thermostaten nicht verstanden
Aber Google hat jetzt einfach mal alle, die Nest verwendet haben
Auf herkömmliche Art und Weise instant
Die haben einfach gesagt
Nö Leute, Nest-RP
Wer braucht schon die Nest-RP
Tja
Das ist auch schon geil
Wie sich das anhört
Google stellt Works with Nest ein
Also sprich, dieses Produkt hieß ursprünglich
Works with Nest
Und jetzt stellen sie die Works with Nest-RP ein
Also jetzt müsste das Ding eigentlich heißen
Doesn't work with Nest oder sowas
Der Name ist schon wieder hängen geblieben
Das stimmt schon
Google hat auch ein paar gescheite Sachen
Chrome ist wirklich nicht übel, kann man nicht sagen
Aber in manchen Sachen sind sie einfach nervig geworden
Link zum Streamerschiff
Wubblowers.tv
Oder maxfps.tv geht auch
In manchen Bereichen
Ist einfach nervig geworden
Es ist ja nicht so, als wären die anderen besser
Auf YouTube gibt es neuesten Doppelwerbung
Vor den Videos und auf Twitch gibt es
Amazon gibt es
Auch bei jeder Video-Switch-Werbung
Alle drehen sie durch
Deswegen ist es doppelt wichtig
Dass man
Wenn man Smart-Home-Geschichten macht
Sich Zeug kauft, was offen ist
Oder was man mit Open Source betreiben kann
Dass man flashen kann
Dann hat man die Probleme
Nämlich alle nicht
Okay
Reset
Das wollen wir setzen
Und das wollen wir auf zwei
Wobei das ist schon auf zwei gesetzt
Aber das andere müssen wir setzen
Starting failed
Gucken wir mal, ob ich richtig verkabelt habe
Ach so, wenn ich richtig verkabelt habe, sehe ich überhaupt nichts
Das ist natürlich eine sehr clevere Entscheidung gewesen
Print
In it
Also sprich, wenn es abkackt, restart
Ansonsten, wenn es hier weiter kommt, ist es okay
Okay
Okay, anscheinend habe ich
Den Krempel schon mal richtig verkabelt
Das ist doch schon mal
Nicht schlecht
Also er erkennt das Modul
Und wie gesagt, man konnte da ein bisschen was kaputt machen
Oder man konnte sich da ein bisschen vertun
Weil das ist dann wirklich das nackte Modul
Ungefähr so groß ist wie ein Daumennagel
Was auch nicht den normalen Pin-Abstand hat
Sondern viel kleiner
Deswegen musste ich so machen
Pin oben, Pin unten, Pin oben, Pin unten, Pin oben
Pin unten, dass die Kabel überhaupt ranpassen
Das Problem an Twitch ist, es gibt keine Alternative
Ist bei Youtube doch im Prinzip genauso
Ist bei Google Mail im Prinzip ähnlich
Ist bei Youtube ähnlich, ist bei Twitch ähnlich, ist bei Amazon ähnlich
Das ist halt das Problem, wenn es halt nur
In einem Bereich eine Sache gibt
Ich meine, es hat auch Vorteile
Ich meine, letztendlich kannst du dich als Content Creator auf Youtube sicher fühlen
Sofern man
Youtube da
Für sicher hält
Youtube passt schon
Aber es ist halt die einzige Plattform, das heißt ich muss mich umsonst nichts kümmern
Also ich muss nicht auf 20 Plattformen aktiv sein
Oder auch nicht auf 2 oder auf 3, sonst kann ich mich ganz auf eine Plattform konzentrieren
Aber es ist halt ein bisschen doof
Wenn es halt nur diese eine Plattform gibt
Für Zuschauer im Endeffekt
Wenn beispielsweise Youtube
Algorithmus der Meinung ist, du willst jetzt nur einen Haftbefehl gucken
Und wenn du dann auch nur ein Video anklickst
Weil du dir denkst, ey was ist das eigentlich für ein Mistwasch empfohlen kriege
Bäm, nächstes Video Haftbefehl
Goethe Straße, Louis Vuitton Store
Zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor
Musste dir da die ganze Zeit anhören
Ja und dann hast du Pech, wenn der Youtube Algorithmus meint
Du willst das sehen, dann musst du das sehen
Allerdings, wenn du ein paar andere Sachen sehen willst
Die die App nicht empfehlen, hast du auch wieder Pech
Und das sind nur die Sachen, die quasi die Logik dahinter
Macht, was einem auf den Keks geht
Die Apps sind absolute Zumutung von Youtube
Max kennt sich ja aus mit dem Contentcreate auf Youtube
Ey es hat immer nur 280.000 Abos gereicht
Vor paar Jahren
Ansonsten, in letzter Zeit mache ich das so wenig
Ich bin doch nicht mal stinkig, dass ich nur noch De-Abos kriege
Weil ich kriege ja keine, keine Dis-Abos
Nennen wir es mal, wo die Leute sagen, oh der Spaß, den deaboniere ich
Weil ich kriege einfach diese Standard Flow
Aus De-Abos, die man kriegt
Aus inaktiven Accounts, aus geschlossenen Accounts
Aus Youtube deabonniert Leute
Und ja, mit Sicherheit wird auch der eine oder andere sagen, ey der Max
Der ist ein Spaß, der lädt nichts hoch
Und das abboh ich jetzt
Ich unterteile die Abos immer in Dis-Abos und De-Abos
De-Abos sind quasi so die
Sachen, wo du nichts dagegen machen kannst
Und Dis-Abos sind quasi die Leute, die sagen
Das will ich immer, die aktiv sagen, das will ich immer gucken
Gegen Dis-Abos kann man im Prinzip was machen
Gegen De-Abos nicht so wirklich
Achja, und
Was mich auch auf Youtube halt nervt, das habe ich gestern schon gesagt
Dass es mittlerweile Doppelpack-Videos gibt und sowas
Haftbefehl macht Werbung
Für eine Zahnpleaching-Firma
Was?
Weil, warum? Ja gut, weil
Haftbefehl, das kann ja machen, was er will
So, wir wollten übrigens, wir wollten Daten übertragen
Anstatt rumlabern
Ok, also wir haben unser LoRa-Modul initialisiert
Jetzt können wir mal eine Nachricht schicken
Closed Session by inactivity
Ok, mein LoRa-Empfänger empfängt noch nichts
Dann können wir jetzt gleich mal ändern
Also wir erstellen ein LoRa-Package
Und da schreiben wir rein
Keine Ahnung, was schreiben wir da rein
Und KS
Und dann senden wir das Packet
Noch ein bisschen Debug-Ausgabe
So dass wir einfach wissen, dass es funktioniert
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob was ankommt
Ich bin da recht zuversichtlich, weil das Modul erkennt er
Das heißt, das sollte passen
Oh, Leute, ist keine so gute Idee
Ich habe kein Delay drinnen
Aber ich empfange was
Ich empfange was
Und zwar MonkaS empfange ich
Also Datenübertragung funktioniert
Ich sollte hier unbedingt mal ein Delay reinmachen
Weil ich haue hier gerade im Millisekunden-Takt
Funkmessages raus, das muss nicht unbedingt sein
MonkaS
Dazu kann ich nur sagen
Wo ist es?
MonkaS
Oh
Oh my god
Warum habe ich diese ganzen Mist-Sounds eigentlich noch drinnen?
So, gucken wir nochmal
Der Delay ist die Übertragungsrate
Ist mein USB-Port gerade verreckt, oder was?
Ich glaube, ich muss noch mal einstöpseln
Diddle diddle diddle
Inchibated Zone
Den habe ich noch nicht drinne
Okay
Ja, aber das funktioniert, also die Datenübertragung funktioniert
Wir haben eigentlich auch einen ganz passablen Empfang
Aber wir haben auch eine ganz passablen Empfang
Wir haben eigentlich auch eine ganz passablen Empfang
Die Datenübertragungsrate
Jetzt muss ich mal einen Modus machen
auch ein ganz passablen empfangen wenn man sich überlegt das ganze geht jetzt durch
drei wende durch das interessante ist eigentlich hier das da das ist signal zu rauschen also
signal noise ratio die ist mit 9,25 eigentlich relativ gut aber gut ich mein das ding soll
in wirklichkeit 1,5 kilometer überbrücken und jetzt steht es bei mir an der haustür
das sind zwar nur ein paar wende aber es werden auf jeden fall noch erheblich mehr wende werden
gibt es eigentlich eine ms wobblos nie gibt es nicht hat ja an weihnachten mal ein bisschen
ein bisschen erzählt da ist da ist nix weiter weiter draus geworden aus der geschichte der
eine oder andere kann sich vielleicht noch erinnern so ok die datenübertragung funktioniert
das doch schon mal ganz gut ich sehe schon wir haben 21.15 ich muss spätestens 22.00
spenden weil ich muss morgen wieder aufstehen aber wisst ihr was gut ist ich habe ich muss
morgen arbeiten und am mittwoch ist feiertag freitag habe ich urlaub das heißt ich bin
dann donnerstag freitag samstag sonntag montag am start und wenn ich bock hab auf gestreme
wird gestreamt und bei mir ist ja meistens ein gutes zeichen wenn ich zwei tage in folge
geschafft habe zu streamen ist es meistens auch stehen die chancen ganz gut dass ich
auch die nächsten tage schaffe zu streben 6 9 stunden streben das kriege ich nicht mal
hin ok also datenübertragung funktioniert das ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel muss man
doch mal sagen oder achso vielleicht sollten wir jetzt noch mal ausgeben ich habe eine
idee wir gucken wir machen mal einen counter wir verschicken mal nicht laufen monkaS wir
machen mal einen counter den wir hochzählen in jeder in jeder message dann sehen wir nämlich
auch schöner ob das ob das ganze funktioniert ne wir machen das anders wir machen sending
dann sagen wir print line oder print und dann schreiben wir was wir senden dann sagen
wir ok mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert donnerstag freitag monkaX es haben nicht alle
es haben nicht alle feiertag ok sending ein guck mal ob es ankommt ja guckt hier der counter
kommt hier an 1 2 3 4 5 und der empfang ist eigentlich ganz ok also laura skaliert halt
auch extrem damit was man hier einstellt wenn man hier 12 einstellt ohne niedrigere bandbreite
ist das viel langsamer beim übertragen also viel viel viel viel viel langsamer so kein
ahnung ein byte alle 5 sekunden aber es geht halt es geht halt kilometerweit planst du das
ttn für laura zu nutzen ja habe ich vor ich will mir aber dazu will ich mir erstmal ordentlich
antenne holen ich will mir ein gateway unter das dach machen oder ans dach je nachdem weil
bei uns in in der hier in in der ecke gibt es kein kein laura zugang kein laura kein
ttn zugang und diesen gateway können wir im endeffekt alle benutzen dann und für mich
ist auch nicht schlecht weil wenn ich das da quasi aufs dach mal habe ich da noch deutlich
besseren empfang weil es ist wie bei allen funkgeschichten höhe von von von sender beziehungsweise
empfänger macht unglaublich viel aus was ist für ein dach für einen feiertag pockers
tag genau ich habe keine ahnung irgendwas christliches wie fast alle feiertage die wir
haben den christlichen irgendwas wohndeichnam ok ich habe keine ahnung ehrlich gesagt ich
war seit
ich bin jetzt 34 ich war seit
25 jahre in der kirche oder so ich habe auch nicht vor wieder hinzugehen
war eigentlich nur in der kirche wo ich dings kommunionunterricht hatte das hat man damals
so noch gemacht wenn die eltern ein bisschen gläubig waren
bin ich damals hin damals haben wir unsere betreuerin übelst geschockt die ist die ist
zusammengebrochen am ende also jetzt wirklich das bild kann man sich das vor vorstellen
nach der ersten quasi unterrichtstunde ist die zusammengebrochen und es musste eine andere
machen die das war zu viel das war zu viel die gruppe aus aus top wie viel waren wir
irgendwie acht leute oder so in dieser unterrichtsgruppe und für uns war das halt im prinzip zwei
stunden am stück scheiße machen aber das hat die nicht verkraftet da kann ich mich
noch dran erinnern die war fertig mit den nerven danach
so ok also unser counter counted wunderbar und verschickt über laura daten und es kommt
an mit ganz passablen empfang
du warst wohl nicht zufällig in meiner kroppe nee wahrscheinlich nicht ich kann mich kann
mich an keinen florian erinnern den wir in der kroppe hatten
das aber schon ewig her seitdem bin ich da nie wieder hin ich bin ja da eh nur hin weil
es geld gegeben hat also der einzige ich mein freiwillig warum sollte man freiwillig kommunionsunterricht
oder warum sollte man freiwillig dahin gehen ich habe das damals einzig und allein hatte
das monetäre gründe und fast jeden den ich kenne sagt er ist dahin wegen der kohle genauso
wie der flow 96 ich habe was ich habe mir von dem firmungsgeld damals ein ipad gekauft
nur gut ich weiß gar nicht was ich mir davon gekauft habe also ich habe ich habe über
1000 mark gekriegt und das ist in dem alter ist das für ein unglaublich viel geld
heute kauft man sich für 3000 ein klo euro ist eigentlich übelst wie soll man wie soll
man es nennen übelst abgehoben oder sich für 3000 euro den klo zu kaufen die stempeln
mussten wir nicht pavillion werden ok aber aus dem verstehen geblieben ein bisschen abgeschriffen
ja wir haben unsere laura datenübertragung gecheckt was wir uns also to do für die nächsten
streben ist ich mache ich mache noch nicht aus was wir uns mal angucken müssen ist wie
man es verschlüsseln kann weil ich will das ganze natürlich verschlüsseln wenn ich irgendwann
mal tnn verwende ist kein ding dann ist das auch alles selbst so ich muss mal gucken wie
man sp 32 wie man weil das ding hat ein hartes hat hardware hardware is einer drauf mit der
man sachen verschlüsseln kann und auch wenn ich nur meine sensorwerte übertrage vielleicht
will ich sie ja trotzdem verschlüsseln warum is und kein rsa weil ich einfach auf beiden
seiten den schlüssel hinterlege und gut ist prüf sum machen wir auch prüf sum sind glaube
ich super simpel allerdings müsste ich die glaube ich auf client und auf sende einschalten
achja genau wir müssen noch ein paar optionen setzen also die die bandbreite müssen wir
erst mal die bandbreite müssen wir erst mal setzen das ist jetzt aktuell die fault bandbreite
müssen wir setzen wir müssen die oft ich mich schon verschrieben hat weil der du da ein
großes r drin hat wir müssen den sprenning factor setzen das ist wie lang jedes einzelne
mit übertragen wird und wir setzen mal die leistung beim senden hoch und zwar auf 20
bamm da gucken wir mal ob unsere werte noch ein bisschen besser noch besser werden läuft
eigentlich wolf ssl auf dem esp ich habe keine ahnung was wolf ssl ist ne die werte erinnern
sich erinnern sich in null was was ist wolf ssl ist das ein fork von open ssl ne wird
wahrscheinlich auf dem esp nicht laufen man braucht aber auch gar keine keine ssl library
oder sowas ne extra ne weil es ist schon eine dabei so und so könnte man eigentlich hiermit
könnte eigentlich was verschlüsseln und das ist auch ein open source projekt auf github
also es ist gar nicht mal so dass man keine ahnung hat was das was wie das wie das funktioniert
oder man könnte nachgucken wenn man da sache nicht traut ja hiermit habe ich aber noch nie
gemacht muss man das nächste mal angucken maximale sendeleistung ja wohl mehr als 20
geht leider nicht aber allerdings man sieht auch das hat jetzt nicht allzu viel gebracht
die ssnr sind ticken besser geworden aber die war vorher schon ziemlich gut
ach ja ich wollte noch den batterieverbrauch abfragen da habe ich nämlich was schönes
gefunden das probieren wir jetzt einmal aus es gibt also der esp also die kleine variante
von dem controller den ich verwende da ist es ziemlich einfach die betriebsspannung
quasi abzufragen einfach esp get vcc das gibt es allerdings beim esp 32 nicht hat sich
der hersteller nämlich gedacht ja das ist das ist ja total unnütz warum möchte irgendjemand
die spannung abfragen also man hat jetzt bloß die möglichkeit man kann ein kabel nehmen
man nimmt einfach einen kabel von 3,3 volt auf den adc und guckt einfach wie viel reinkommt
dann brauchen wir ein extra kabel oder man nimmt habe ich nämlich vorhin gefunden eine
undokumentierte funktion und dann gucken wir mal ob der kram funktioniert
warum sollte das nicht gehen
weil die referenzspannung gleich zellspannung gleich analoge eingang ist also immer maximal
3,3 volt da stehen zwar am pin dran aber da wird nix großartig rum geregelt also sprich
wenn das wenn das irgendwie runter fällt irgendwann mal auf 2,7 kurz bevor er ausgeht müsste ich
eigentlich am 3,3 volt pin müsste ich 2,7 haben aber muss ich ehrlich sagen ich kenne
mich damit nicht ganz ganz so gut aus undokumentierte funktion ja wie ging das denn jetzt nochmal
hier ich kann mich noch daran erinnern das habe ich vorhin nämlich gefunden irgendwas
mit vdd 33 hieß das und dann irgendwas mit mit puss oder so ich habe es auf reddit gefunden
gucken wir doch mal nach ich gucke jetzt einfach mal schnell meine history dann finde ich das
wieder ist ja schön wenn man sich den kram alles speichert hier ich habe es und undokumentierte
funktion vom von in der firme ja herzlichen glückwunsch jenky wer fällt mir dazu jetzt
auch nicht ein aber mist ein adc nicht zur referenz also wenn du 7,2 volt als versorgen
hast ja wahrscheinlich klingt furchtbar logisch was du sagst schuss 19 irgendeine referenz
brauchste ja aber ich habe einen pin das steht a ref dran vielleicht ist das die referenz
spannung die man verwenden kann ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht keine ahnung wir gucken
erst mal was was das hier was hier rompü get vd 33 was was das was das sagt ok machen wir
mal eine extra funktion wollte read battery ich nenne es mal battery weil im prinzip am
ende ist es eine batterie machen man int draus und mal gucken was das ding zurückliest was
das ding zurück gibt ich habe gelesen man muss man muss auf jeden fall wlan wlan oder
bluetooth einschalten dass diese funktion was ordentliches zurück gibt schaue man mal
was da rauskommt rest machen wir mal auf hier ach komm lass mal drin sonst muss ich das
delay neu schrauben mal gucken was er misst ohne bluetooth an
also susch 19 das klingt wirklich logisch was du sagst warum ist auto gefrickel auto
ist doch vollkommen legitim das ding ist genauso statisch typisiert wie es immer ist nur dass
man den typ nicht hinschreiben muss und wenn man wissen will kann man zweifelsfall einfach
die maus drüber machen da weiß man ist ein int ok ich messe hier angeblich gerade 351
oder was auch immer könnte das 3,5 sein könnte das 3,5 volt sein man würde ungefähr passen
bisschen mehr als 3,3 ich kann es jetzt leider nicht an die batterie anschließen weil da
sehen wir hier nichts mehr die sind sehr genau mit 3,3 volt ich könnte jetzt ich könnte
jetzt ja mal ein multimeter holen und es dran halten und gucken was für eine spannung
das machen wir jetzt mal leute ich hole jetzt mal ein multimeter raus und ich gucke mal was
für eine spannung auf dem 3,3 volt pin ist gucken wir mal vorher muss ich aber mal das
ganze laura zeug hier auskommentieren weil ich dazu das laura modul teilweise abstöpseln
muss ok multimeter wo ist es wo hat sich es hingestellts labeldrucker irgendwo in der
nähe vom labeldrucker ist es das weiß ich das liegt immer irgendwo in der nähe wo habe
ich das denen da ist das kabel guckt raus da muss es sein ja ja ok ja ja mal gucken mal
gucken was es sagt ok weg noch ein kabel dran ich habe auch extra schon die in weißer voraussicht
nicht die standard prüf prüf prüf spitzen bei multimeter dran sondern die für pins die
man so dran klipsen kann und ich hoffe ich kill jetzt mein modul nicht damit ich stöpsel
mein modul mal ab bevor ich das multimeter dran mache so und dann schauen wir mal erst
mal muss ich das ding einstellen auf 600 milli ne 6 volt stellen wir mal ein dann stöpseln
wir das mal hier um den richtigen ich sehe es jetzt leider nicht das muss man als nächstes
holen noch einen usb multimeter dass man die wert sieht den ich messe so dann ziehen wir
mal hier ground ab und wir ziehen wo ist der 3,3 volt pin und wir ziehen 3,3 volt ab und
jetzt machen wir mal das multimeter dran und schauen was passiert hat ein multimeter keine
serielle schrittstelle ich finde es ja toll so dass dann dass die leute jetzt schon im chat
schreiben hat ein multimeter kein rs 232 können einfach sagen serielle schrittstelle dass
jeder was weiß was gemeint ist aber das ist nicht wahnsinnig genug ne hat es nicht das
ist ein ganz das ist kein es ist kein super billiges aber es ist jetzt auch kein sonderlich
gutes ja also es ist nicht so schlimm wie china kacke aber es ist jetzt auch kein wie
heißen die dinger fluke oder so die richtig guten ne das weiß bestimmt flo oder wie ist
die heißt nicht fluke fluke oder so die richtig guten oder hersteller flunke flunke genau
flunke was ok so ich hab mal multimeter angeklipsert angeklipsert so schauen wir mal was da rauskommt
ich mach das jetzt mal nicht runterfallen nicht runterfallen nicht runterfallen was
was rum gebastelt hier so mal anschließen mal gucken was passiert hier rum kennt ihr
das usb stöpsel aus prinzip immer immer falsch rum hast du usb anschluss immer jetzt
habe ich schon dreimal getreten finde immer noch nicht die richtige reine richtung vom
usb anschluss jetzt so wir haben auf drei ich mach mal die serielle schrittstelle an
dass wir was sehen also ich mess gerade 3,269 volt auf dem 3,3 volt pin fluke nicht funke
ja ich wusste nur das ungefähr wie der kram heißt also das passt mit dem wert nicht so
ganz allerdings ist die sache ja auch die eigentlich müsste ja gut je nachdem wo es
misst ne also input ist 5 volt usb allerdings der esp 32 selber läuft halt ausschließlich
mit 3,3 volt das heißt eigentlich müsste ich da jetzt mal eine batterie dran stöpseln
und wir müssten die mit einer batterie müsste man das mit einer batterie laufen lassen
was die sagen du sollst einen spannungsteiler machen und über den adc pin gehen auf 1,1
volt gesetzt das könnte ich machen aber ich habe da ich kann ja in die box gar kein bord
rein stecken ok also wir machen mal ne batterie dran wo hab ich denn hier mal ne batterie hier
hab ich ne batterie das ist ne 3,7 volt 2000 milliampere stunden lithium things akku würd
ich mal sagen allerdings ist der voll geladen also der hat wahrscheinlich input irgendwas
um 4,2 oder so ja die widerstelle mussten die können ich höchstens irgendwie kann
ich nicht mal richtig dran löten miss doch die batterie ja ja das könnte ich mal machen
ich könnte ich messe erstmal ich messe erstmal mit dem multimeter mess ich mal die batterie
und dann gucken wir was da 3,3 volt raus kommt also ich denke mal wenn die batterie halt
mehr hat dann wird es das schon nicht auf dem 3,3 volt oder auf den gpio pins raushauen
weil es einfach sensoren kaputt machen würde ok ich stöpsel das mal wieder aus was ein
gefuddelt ok machen wir das mal wieder weg jetzt gucken wir mal was der akku was der akku
hat gucken ob ich das mit diesen prüf mit diesen komischen prüf oh fuck komischen prüf
dingern hier überhaupt hinkriegen oder ob ich dann die normalen prüf spitzen nehmen
muss nein ich muss die normalen prüf spitzen nehmen ja fuck der komm ich an den akku nicht
dran wo ist denn hier die normale hier hier sind die normalen prüf spitzen mit denen
können wir das einmal ausprobieren das hatte ich heute eigentlich gar nicht vor hier irgendwelche
wir wollen informatiker zeug machen und kein elektroniker zeug oh jetzt hab ich die batterie
weggeschmissen mit dem kabel grad zack batterie komm her so halten wirs mal an die batterie
dran das hat so einen kleinen kack stecker da kommst du überhaupt richtig dran zweifelsfall
vorsicht jetzt noch in kurzschluss mit den dingern und die ganze batterie verreckt ja
also 4,179 volt hat die batterie haben wir das auch ausprobiert
also die ist voll geladen das ding ist bis zum anschlag ok ich stöpsel den krams grad
mal wieder an was machen wir jetzt was hatte ich jetzt eigentlich vor genau wir stöpseln
ich lasse mir jetzt das hier mal auslesen ich lasse mir das jetzt auslesen wie kann
ich mir das jetzt schicken lassen ich hab halt nur ein 3,3 volt pin ich kann das ans
kabel halten das passt der controller brennt nicht durch weil der hat nen batterie eingang
mit nem spannungsregler davor übrigens können wir das komplett vergessen was ich grad erzählt
hab weil der controller mit dem ich das hier grade mache ist der der kein batterieanschluss
hat ja der hat schon nen regler am batterie eingang drinnen der ist zugelassen bis glaube
ich maximal 4,5 oder so guck da der hält das auf jeden fall aus ich hab das auch schon
drangehängt da passiert nichts aber das können wir jetzt ja gar nicht ausprobieren aber was
wir machen können ist wir können mal nen kabel achja übrigens vollkommener Mist den ich
hier eigentlich grad erzählt hab weil die haben ja gesagt man soll plutus vorher einschalten
bevor man das liest also mal plutus start und plutus stopp und gucken wir was dann zurück
kommt 6000 ach was mach ich da blödsinn
6547 ja gut die sache ist jetzt es ist halt absolut keine ahnung was dieser wert am jetzt
genau sagen soll vielleicht muss man das nur noch durch irgendwas teilen oder sonst
wie ich hab doch auf reddit irgendwas gefunden vorher wo irgendeiner erzählt hat er hat
was rausgekriegt am besten am liebsten wäre mir es wenn man das einfach intern direkt
auslesen könnte achja guck mal hier haben wir doch schon was internal reading 2798 ne
da sind wir ein bisschen weit von weg von meinem internal reading aber durch zwei teilen
und gucken was rauskommt ob das irgendwie plausibel ist
das sieht ziemlich brauchbar aus das das ist ziemlich genau das was ich mit meinem
multimeter vorhin gemessen hab ich mein das kann jetzt auch nur zufällig sein ne
das kann jetzt auch so malen nach zahlen wir teilen das einfach so lang bis wir rauskriegen
was man was man was man haben will das müsste man jetzt mal müsste man jetzt mal ausprobieren
mit einer batterie ich werde das mal ausprobieren noch durch 69 teilen ja ich muss jetzt erst
den anderen controller holen die batterie anschließen oder kann man die dinger auch
direkt über den pin power keine ahnung ich will ich will ihn nicht kaputt machen ich
werde es mal ausprobieren ich muss jetzt den anderen controller holen dass wir das
mit der batterie ausprobieren können und ich muss die batterie erstmal ein bisschen
entladen naja scheiß drauf ich werde mal wieder den laura controller anstöpseln eins
habe ich mittlerweile gelernt nachdem ich ein paar sachen kaputt gemacht habe immer crown
zuerst anschließen weil sonst manchmal irgendwie rip und das an den richtigen pin dran und
mal gucken ob es wieder funktioniert ich nee ne kochan so viel also ich habe gar nicht
so viel kaputt gemacht eine sache kann in letzter zeit wo ich mich dran erinnern kann
ich zerstört habe ist so ein halter für eine batterie gewesen das ist aber nicht nur
ein halter das war komplettes komplettes lade ladeprogramm da drauf und zwar auf das
auch ein aliexpress ding gewesen aliexpress was war das für ein ding aber ich sag zeig's
euch mal ja so ein teil plus halt der da ja das teil eins davon habe ich geschrottet
weil ich die batterie falsch rum reingemacht habe das ist halt billig china kram die haben
da ja auch nichts eingebaut dass das irgendwie davor schützen würde ne ist übrigens viel
zu teuer kost bei aliexpress 2 euro dafür ist es nicht schlimm der batterie hat es
nichts gemacht und ich habe mir einen 10er pack gekauft für jeweils für 2 euro und
die dinger sind wirklich ganz praktisch auch auch also ich habe mir die dinger habe ich
mir eigentlich gekauft als raspberry usv weil raspberry piles ja ganz gerne mal dazu
neigen wenn du ihnen den strom abziehst dass sie kaputt gehen ich allerdings ab und zu
mal meine raspberry piles abziehen muss oder ab und zu auch mal vielleicht der strom nicht
immer 100 prozentig da ist wie auch immer habe ich jetzt jedem raspberry pile sofern
es möglich war vom standort her eine mini usv damit verpasst funktioniert eigentlich
ganz gut einfach batterie rein keine normale batterie das muss so eine dicke 18 650 sein
und dann stöpselst du den raspberry einfach hier auf den usb anschluss ran und das wird
versorgt und das schöne an dem module ist die haben da auch einen lade einen lade chip
oder wie auch immer man das genau nennt drauf also sprich der kann gleichzeitig laden und
entladen und erkennt auch wie bei einer usv wenn quasi der input weg ist und betreibt
es dann aus der batterie er hält wie lange noch kommt drauf an was du auf deine raspberry
machst können wir doch mal ausrechnen ganz einfach also so ne so ne so ne batterie hat
ungefähr sagen wir mal 2000 milliampere stunden was hatten so ne was haben die so standardmäßig
2000 900 das erscheint jetzt schon fast ein bisschen viel aber doch sagen wir mal 3000
milliampere stunden haben die 3000 milliampere stunden hat die batterie dein raspberry läuft
halt durchgehend das lebt gar nicht und dein raspberry wird so so irgendwas idel keine
ahnung 300 milliampere oder so verbrauchen oder so ungefähr in dem dreh sleep sleep
gibt es nicht machen wir mal eins sleep time null execution zwei oder was kann man da eintragen
20 sleep time null execution of code null eins macht keinen unterschied dauerhaft dauerhaft
an das hier dürfte auch keinen unterschied machen genau also ein raspberry dürfte so
ungefähr acht stunden damit laufen na 50 ne ne ne ne also 50 hatten raspberry auf nie
und nimmer noch nicht mal ein zero ich mein wir könnten es jetzt ausprobieren weil ich
hab mir so ein schönes usb so ein usb strommesser gekauft auch so ein china ding aber das ist
wirklich praktisch so ein ding hier das da so ein gelb ich mach mir da auch keine gedanken
also normalerweise würde ich mir alles was irgendwie elektronik also wo bisschen mehr
spannung ein bisschen mehr strom drüber geht würde ich mir ein paar china sachen immer
vorsichtig sein also ich würde mir beispielsweise auch keine china relays in meine hier mein
lichtschalter oder so einbauen aber bei diesen fünf volt und maximal 500 milliampere die
so einen usb anschluss hat drauf geschissen und das ding ist wirklich praktisch das stöpselst
dann usb anschluss ein stöpselst auf der anderen seite hat alle möglichen anschlüsse
mikro usb usb c sonst was eingang ausgang und da siehst du direkt was für eine spannung
du drauf hast also das sollten immer irgendwas um 5 volt sein bei usb und du siehst auch
genau was das ding braucht was dran hängt und du kannst es auch umschalten was auch
nicht welche langzeit grafen das wirklich sehr praktisch das ist echt cool das heißt
ich könnte das jetzt einstöpseln und ich könnte mal den raspberry dran hängen und
wir könnten mal gucken was der idol verbraucht kann ich euch gleich sagen machen wir mal
machen wir mal ich habe hier was ist denn das für einer das ist ein ob das noch ein zweier
den ich hier liegen habe das ist auch ein raspberry 2 ok gucken wir mal was ein raspberry 2 verbraucht
im idol ich musste mal gucken ob ich die sd karte auch rausgenommen habe ja schauen wir
mal was das ding idol so verbraucht sage ich gleich hier anschließen weil ich kann es
wieder nicht einstöpseln weil usb anschluss zu fett dann stöpsel ich sie hier ein so
den raspberry dran so raspberry geht an verkackt natürlich den boot weil keine sd karte drin
ist und verbraucht gerade 68 milliampere das ist aber jetzt halt null der ist der konnte
ich mal booten ich könnte mal einen zero anschließen ist egal ist jetzt wurscht also
der raspberry braucht wenn er wirklich komplett idol ist im boot hängt also sprich da sind
wahrscheinlich auch die ganzen gpio sache noch nicht initialisiert und nichts drauf
braucht ja schon 68 milliampere also im betrieb irgendwas zwischen irgendjemand hat gerade
geschrieben 100 bis 300 das das kommt eigentlich hin ich denke mal dass es wahrscheinlich bis
zu 500 oder so rauf geht sogar oder noch mehr wenn wenn er was macht also ich denke wenn
ein dreier ordentlich was laufen hat auf allen vier kern wirst du wahrscheinlich auch wahrscheinlich
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr brauchen max wird maximal zeit geträgt er ist ok weil ich muss
eh gleich auf so mal ab machen das ganze ding aber das schöne ist ich habe die ganzen mist
hier mittlerweile rumliegen das heißt wir können können sowas ohne probleme immer mal
zwischendurch ausprobieren mein ziel ist es ja irgendwie wenn wir hier noch mehr so technik
streams machen dass ich es mal irgendwie schaffe mir geräte zu holen die man schön per usb
auslesen kann das geht das übrigens das ist das ist ganz ganz meta das ist so ein usb
ding was man selbst offiziell nur per smartphone ab auslesen kann aber ich habe auf github
schon ein projekt gefunden wo man das usb strom gerät über usb auslesen kann das ist
ein usb seption irgendwo naja aber gehen wir mal von aus ich denke das ist ein halbwegs
realistischer wert dass dein raspberry ungefähr 300 milliampere verbraucht dann hast du mit
einer voll geladenen batterie da drinne hast du ungefähr acht stunden dauer das ist doch
echt ist doch in ordnung damit kommt man aus
hä ne warum das macht das ding schon alles ja das macht das alles das kannst du usb
anschließen da kommen schon fünf voll raus da musst du nix machen da kommt alles raus
was du für usb brauchst ist da schon alles drauf und du kannst auch direkt du kannst
nehmen kannst du 3 3,3 volt abgreifen dreimal und hier neben die was man jetzt hier nicht
sieht noch mal noch mal fünf was für die zellen lebensdauer jetzt kann jetzt kann
ich dir gerade nicht mehr folgen irgendwie ich habe doch gar keinen einfluss drauf was
das ding macht das ist doch ist doch von den chinesen schon fertig so gebaut und ich gehe
auch mal davon aus dass das ding die zelle rechts also die den akku rechtzeitig abschalten
wird zumal wahrscheinlich die das ding sich selbst abschaltet bei keine ahnung noch 15
prozent oder so keine ahnung also was ich ganz cool finde ist also was ich cool finden
würde wenn das hier stimmt stimmt ach das meinst du ja das ist das ist richtig flor
ja klar ja ja ok jetzt weiß ich was du meinst ok stimmt da ist unsere rechnung natürlich
nicht nicht allzu optimal das stimmt ja aber selbst selbst wenn das nur nur so viel übrig
bleiben würde läuft immer noch eine stunde also wie dem auch sei für den raspberry als
usb ist es mehr als ausreichend dieses ding mit einer batterie drinnen nicht mehr als
ausreichend ja ok jetzt habe ich gecheckt was du meinst nicht dass man das einbauen
soll sondern dass man das einfach nicht so rechnen kann weil wir ein bisschen bisschen
unterwegs sachen verlieren der war schlecht der war schlecht er war genauso schlecht wie
das usb nehmen den usa liegt aber ich finde schon mal ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut
dass wir ungefähr so was hier auslesen wie ich mit meinem multimeter gerade gemessen
habe das macht mich recht zuversichtlich dass das ich weil ich habe jetzt einfach random
durch zwei geteilt warum auch immer aber vielleicht bringt das ja was ich stoppe den jetzt hier
immer vom publishing 2 confirmed aber es stimmt schon man muss man muss bluetooth starten
sonst funktioniert das ganze nicht aber was auch immer drauf geschissen es probiere ich
dann probieren wir mal in einem anderen streben weiter aus und dann nehme ich auch ein bord
wo ich eine batterie anschließen kann und ich mache die batterie auch mal ein bisschen
leer macht die batterie mal ein bisschen leer so dass dann keine ahnung nur noch drei volt
rauskommen oder so
ja flo mag alles sein ich habe da nicht so den nicht so den plan von ich gehe zumindest
mal davon aus dass diese geschichte mit der batterie hier aber so ist dass es für den
raspberry locker als usb reicht und ob das hier jetzt so wirklich genau ist und ob das
auch nur annähernd hinkommt ist eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig solange es irgendwie
halbwegs so bisschen hinkommt weil dann erkenne ich auch dass die batterie leer wird und ich
mal einfach tauschen muss aber ich habe da einen anderen ansatz wenn ich was nicht so
genau checken da gucke ich entweder nach bis ich checken oder wenn es was einfaches ist
dann probiere ich einfach ein paar mal aus mit unterschiedlichen bedingungen und dann
weiß ich ob stimmt oder nicht ich werde es jetzt nämlich so machen ich werde einfach
zu überprüfen ob das hier stimmt ich nehme jetzt einfach mal eine batterie die hier fast
entladen ist oder so was gerade noch mit funktioniert englisch mal dran dann nehme ich hier den
einen akku ein bisschen entladen und man vollen akku und guck einfach was das ding ausspuckt
und dann genau und dann teilen wir im zweifelsfall das immer durch die richtigen zahlen bis
das richtige rauskommt sagen wir nicht random wozu brauchst eine usb für den raspberry dass
er nicht kaputt geht wobei der raspberry nicht kaputt geht sondern die sd karte und die sd
karte geht auch nicht kaputt sondern die sd karte wird nur kaputt gemacht also datalsystem
mäßig kaputt gemacht man muss sie dann neu flaschen und das passiert beim raspberry tatsächlich
ziemlich häufig also ich hatte schon öfters als ich jetzt irgendwie mit fingern abzählen
kann eine sd karte oder ein paar sd karten waren auch schon komplett kaputt das zertifiziert
ja das wird kaputt also die sind also die raspberries sind bekannt dafür vor allem die
zeros dass wenn du einfach strom abziehst dass der ist die sd karte oder dass das fallsystem
auf der sd karte schrottet das kannst du überall lesen und deswegen dachte ich mir ist so eine
mini usb für den raspberry gar nicht verkehrt ja etikett das kann auch passieren also ich
wie gesagt ich hatte auch eins zwei diese waren schon komplett schrott aber die waren
auch die sd karten waren auch schrott mittlerweile kann man aber glaube ich sogar den raspberry
auch von usb booten das war bei den älteren ja immer ein bisschen größere akt aber es
halt die frage ob man das will ich meine letztendlich willst du was kompaktes haben was da nicht
auch noch irgendwie eine externe usb oder eine externe ssd oder so rumstehen hat dann
aber man die selbst so eine kleine ssd ist halt dreimal so groß wie der raspberry so
rein von der fläche her und du könntest man könnte halt einen ordentlichen usb stick nehmen
aber ob der usb stick jetzt so viel besser ist als eine ordentliche sd karte also wisst
ihr so in so in so nur nach 15 usb stick ob der so viel besser ist als so nur nach 15
sd karte keine ahnung man könnte sich natürlich so eine so eine ssd als usb stick nehmen gibt
es ja mittlerweile auch ein paar das wird auf jeden fall was bringen aber dann bezahlst
du 60 euro noch mal obendrauf gibt es übrigens neue ich muss mal schnell was gucken bevor
ich jetzt oft gehe gibt es eigentlich ordentliche mal wieder ordentliche kits wo nur das wichtigste
drin ist ich mein 80 euro ist viel zu teuer das ist mir auch noch ein ticken zu teuer
aber das geht ja noch irgendwo ein terabyte sd karte so taugt das kit lasst mal gucken
weil ich bräuchte noch eins zwei raspberries ich bräuchte nämlich mal ein neun für meinen
3d drucker also für für octopie und ich bräuchte für mein geplantes laura ttn gateway bräuchte
ich noch einen was ist hier in dem kit alles drinnen ein dreier ist doch ein dreier genau
also ein dreier raspberry ist drinne das offizielle netzteil das offizielle gehäuse ja und wahrscheinlich
die offizielle sd karte wobei das halt china kram ist mit einem ami auf das ist nicht
einfach mit einem richtigen ordentlichen stecker ohne adapter ach nee das ist immer so ne ach
das netzteil war immer so stimmt stimmt sind einfach beides dabei das gehäuse braucht
es nicht aber ich finde die raspberry gehäuse ganz nett wobei das ist das doofe gehäuse
wo keine gpi aus rauskommen oder sie haben mehrere deckel dabei hallo max la bestia das
aber ich finde das set zieht sogar halbwegs brauchbar aus das ist nur das nötigste netzteil
sd karte raspberry pie gehäuse warum kostet warum kostet denn das weiße warum kostet
denn das weiße sieben euro mehr und hier kostet das weiße auch plus 53 und hier kostet das
schwarz jetzt 55 die verwirren mich ach so das sind zwei unterschiedliche dinger ok
was auch immer das ist absolut massive big brain aber 50 euro geht ich mein der nackte
raspberry was kosten der 30 oder so 25 30 hier irgendwie so und das geht das geht auch
noch günstiger wie hieß dieser shop diesmal relativ günstig hatten die hatten es relativ
günstig daher und die was da der raspberry aktuell kostet kann man das irgendwie auf
euro umstellen 36 ok da ist auf amazon sogar günstiger und hier ok ach moment das ist
da kann man sich das tatsächlich bei amazon holen das ist ok und sag mal mal so 20 euro
für das gehäuse das netzteil und sd karte das ist ok ja das geht schon also 50 euro
für das set ist in ordnung ja ich könnte mir das gehäuse selbst trocknen das ist richtig
aber es gibt kein kit mit netzteil und raspberry da nehme ich halt das gehäuse mit da ist
auch noch eine sd karte dabei wobei ich habe es ja schon mal erzählt ne sd karten mangel
habe ich halt echt nicht nachdem mir amazon mal fälschlicherweise so ein karton mit ssd
karten geschickt hat mit ssd mit sd karten geschickt hat hatte irgendwie drei bestellt
dann habe ich irgendwie 20 gekriegt das ist genug oder 25 ist genug auf jeden fall 32
g ja aber wisst ihr ich habe da auch wirklich kein schlechtes gewissen ich bestelle so viel
zeug bei amazon und amazon wird von 20 sd karten nicht ahm achja und ne sache die ich
auch mal unbedingt gucken wollte das mache ich jetzt auch schnell bevor ich off gehe
kannst du noch mal ein video streamen oder ein video zu deinem neuen server machen also
neu die habe ich noch nicht alle aufgebaut aber falls du diese große kiste meinst die
ich mal im video gezeigt habe die ist die wird mittlerweile gerade abgelöst durch kleinere
stromsparendere zwei kisten gibt es sowas hier eigentlich weil ich habe aktuell einfach
nur diese jede menge davon das problem ist dass ich am liebsten eigentlich nur rot schwarz
hätte hauptsächlich weil rot schwarz brauchste immer und die anderen brauche ich viel weniger
ich hätte gerne diese kabel so im verhältnis sagen wir mal 22 zu eins irgendwie ne also
zwei schwarze zwei rote auf ein blaues und auf ein gelbes und so achte mit dem editing
schwarz oder mit dem editing rot oder so deswegen habe ich mir ja vielleicht gibt es vielleicht
gibt es die dinger ja einfarbig wir gucken mal bei unserem china mann unseres vertrauens
ob die sowas haben
war nur in der anzeige ist raus warum soll ich da mitglied werden um zu suchen dann doch
ganz dicht alter aliexpress was geht mit euch ab
warum soll ich mich einlocken um zu suchen muss man doch sonst nie
hat seit wann muss man sich einlocken auf aliexpress zu suchen
drehen die chinesen stehen komplett komplett durch jetzt
was ist mit aliexpress los
gut dann gucken wir halt dann gucken wir halt bei dem in der unseres vertrauens ich finde
auch die adresse irgendwie banggood klingt irgendwie schon
haben die sowas vielleicht den neuen schwarzen das nicht
haben wir irgendwie nicht
die will ich nicht ich will wirklich die ordentlichen die female to male
die pond die pond wie auch immer kabel rot schwarz und dann ab und zu ein paar blau
und auch keine ahnung weiß drauf na gut
ja wie gesagt aliexpress ist der china mann meines vertrauens und banggood ist der der
inder meines vertrauens also solange es nicht darum geht es an die steckdose anzuschließen
wohl gemerkt
so leute ich muss ich muss jetzt ins bett ich muss morgen früh wieder um 5 uhr 30 aufstehen
allerdings nur noch dienstag mittwoch arbeiten nächste woche oder diese woche und dann habe
ich wieder zeit und nachdem das streben in die letzten tage so gut funktioniert hat hoffe
ich mal dass das die nächste woche weil man sagt nächste woche diese woche auch gut funktionieren
wird ja danke für die follows und
wir machen jetzt schluss ich sag mal machts gut bis zum nächsten mal tschüss bis denn
zu
Und das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.